[Music]
on a day of mourning in uvalde the visit
that every city must dread the motorcade
of a president carrying a nation's
condolences for unimaginable loss
joe and jill biden went straight to the
memorial at the robb elementary school
the scene of such horror on tuesday
president and first lady herself a
teacher of course
paying their respects
and then at the pictures of each of
those who died 19 children and two
teachers stopping to reflect
this has become a sad ritual for
american presidents so many victims of
gun violence in so many communities
but for the people of uvalde at the end
of such a traumatic week thoughts were
with their neighbors who lost so much
we we go home to our kids and
unfortunately they can't and this is
something that
you've always been remembered because of
this tragedy and it's one thing that
you know you don't want to be remembered
this way you always want to be
remembering something positive
a mile from the scene of the shooting
the bidens attended mass a president who
talks a lot about his faith in a
community that has turned to it for
solace
away from the cameras he met the
families of those who died and some of
the first responders who tried to save
them
[Music]
the questions about the speed of the
police response on tuesday have now
prompted the department of justice to
open what they call a critical incident
review to see if lessons can be learned
just one of the reckonings america is
facing
while this visit was about consoling and
supporting the community joe biden knows
there are big questions for politicians
including him
about whether anything can be done to
change a culture that allows these
things to happen those wanting gun
reform say he should declare a national
emergency to take personal control of
what they say is a crisis
this was the chant that confronted the
president here a plea for him to do
something
[Applause]
we will he replied but is that a promise
he can keep
the memorials continue to grow in uvalde
whether what happened here does bring
any change in america they are
determined the lives lost here
will never be forgotten
and we can speak to greg in uvalde now
gregor what is the prospect of anything
happening what's next
well the pressure is growing when you
think joe biden was making one of these
visits to buffalo 12 days ago now he's
doing it here
it seems at the moment that he wants
congress to act despite all those calls
for him to do something as you as you
heard there there is talk that congress
has a plan in place pushed by democrats
of course that would see
background checks what they call a red
flag warning system where people who
pose a threat to themselves or others
who have access to guns
would raise an alert some more money for
school funding mental health funding as
well
but we've been here before of course and
after sandy hook nearly 10 years ago
there were similar suggestions of
similar laws and they didn't go anywhere
so it could well come down to joe biden
and executive action to to do something
about this but i think they feel it will
depend a lot on the public it will
depend on the public calling their
representatives to push for action this
time and certainly the public feeling
here is very strong all day we've seen
people from this town and towns all
around this area queuing up to lay
flowers at the memorial the feelings
here very strong and i think the
president saw that when he was here
today